на ЗК виявило майна невідомо Звідки
взятого у воєнкомів більше ніж на чверть
мільярда гривень лідер Одеський воєнком
Борисов але там інші воєнкоми просто
капец інша історія пам'ятаєте той
прокурор який святкував весілля під
Львовом так що арабські шейхи їм стало
стидно за свою скромність Ну і 100 000
грн торт і все інше ну йому зараз
вручили повістку це що покарання за
повістка А як там антикорупційні
розслідування Ну а в цей час Чим зайняті
антикорупціонери Національне
антикорупційне бюро України спрямувало в
суд справу на 3 млн грн по розкраданню
семян на 3 млн в них бюджет більше
мільярда Вони мають займатися
топкорупцією Кирилом Тимошенко
гетьманцевим татаровим єрмаком
врешті-решт нуні сімена на 3 млн грн Ну
тому що О так отце це і получається